[Music]
our first question today is from sabrina
on patreon
what does good emotional health look
like and what's the best way to achieve
it you know
susan so in your book they're on page 59
you talk about the good news about bad
moods
and so i want to talk about this and we
were talking about it a bit on the
maximal episode which we already
recorded how unfortunately we moralize
everything happiness is good and sadness
is bad
and anger is bad but bliss is good and
what you've done especially with this
book i'll hold it up here it's called
emotional agility
and what you've done in the book is
you've helped separate that moralizing
of every emotion because it's not merely
about experiencing only the pleasurable
emotions the good emotions and then
shunning the bad emotions we in fact we
had a question about grief and how grief
can be loving and beautiful and
necessary yeah
and yet we're often just looking for
the good in fact it's even in this
question what does good emotional health
look like and i'm reminded of a mystic i
heard someone asked him if he gets angry
he said it's not that i'm not capable of
anger
but i don't give anyone the privilege of
making me angry
and it was uh
this morning ryan said something and he
was like are you am i frustrating you
and i was like you don't have the power
to frustrate me only i have the power to
frustrate me only i have the power to
make me angry only i have the power to
make myself upset now of course our
environment affects us in different ways
but generally it has to do with the
expectations we set and then when the
environment doesn't comport with our
expectations that's when we feel those
negative emotions yeah
there's this beautiful um quote which is
expectations or disappointments waiting
to happen
i love it i love it yes
i actually don't know who's it's not
mine i don't know who it's from but but
i i spoke about about a bit in the book
um
yeah i mean the the traditional way of
dealing with and it connects with this
question our emotions is that they're
good or bad positive or negative um and
this is a rigid view that is not uh true
to the reality of our experience i mean
charles darwin described how our
difficulty like it tells no one
describes how all of our emotions all of
our emotions help us to communicate with
ourselves what are my needs what do i
care about what are my values and others
what are their needs what are their
values and so on
and so a really important part of
emotional health is
moving away from
hustling with whether you are or aren't
allowed to feel something
and instead
facing into the fact that you do feel it
in in emotional agility i talk about how
acceptance
is the prerequisite to change and it's
this remarkable paradox that we have in
our own lives it's it's like only when
you accept
face into the reality of what is
that you can move forward into what
could be and when i say acceptance i
don't mean passive resignation i don't
mean like oh my goodness you know i'm
sad now i i don't feel like getting out
of bed and there's nothing i can do
there if i'm going to stay but you know
i don't mean passive resignation i mean
acceptance of what is you know only when
we
face into
a world in which people are unseen and
we accept and recognize that we can
actually start changing it only when we
accept that climate change
is a fact and we recognize that reality
will always have its way
that we
are able to change that and so you know
you speak about anger um i'm reminded
my south african accent so so i grew up
as a white child
in the white suburbs of apartheid south
africa
and it was very much a country and a
community committed uh
to not seeing to not seeing other
people's pain to not seeing and to
denial
and
i
found so remarkable in that context the
words of nelson mandela you know nelson
mandela
had a
remarkable relationship with his anger
and what he described is how
firstly
his anger
helped him to connect with what he cared
about
so i would actually suggest that anger
is a very very important emotion there
is no
change that has ever happened in our
communities or in our society without
anger yeah okay
so anger is crucial but one of the
things that charles darwin uh so
told darwin one of the things that
mandela described is how
it was the
recognition
of his anger and what his anger was
signposting about his values
that then
in his words
enabled him to sit down with his
oppressors
and i think this is remarkable and it's
worth giving pause to because a core
part of my work is the idea that
emotions are data
emotions are data emotions tell us what
we care about
but emotions are not
directives
all right and this is really important
just because i feel angry doesn't mean i
get to have it out with anyone doesn't
mean i get to act with impunity
so it's almost like if we can kind of
step into our emotions and we can say
what are the data that these emotions
are signposting what what is being
threatened here what value that's
important to me is being threatened
so we can use those data
but we aren't
letting them be directives we are
instead of
letting that anger hold us we are
instead stepping into our values
so they the emotions are data they're
not directives what are the directives
our values our wisdom and and this is so
important because often when we get
hooked when we see on twitter or when
people get really you know upset about
something and it's like they're upset
because their values have been
contravened
but they're operating
out of their rage
rather than into their values yes and
when you operate out of your rage you
actually
are very often going against your values
that's right you know you often are now
breaking down communication
and so i love this notion from nelson
mandela because it was this idea of
i'm not turning away from my anger
i'm learning from my anger and it's the
learning about my values that allows me
to then have the conversations that i
need to have in order to create change
oh that's beautiful
because
the emotions in a way and i wrote this
down as we were preparing for this
episode emotions are like children you
can love them without letting them run
the show
yes i i emotions of data not directives
i can show up to my son's frustration
with his baby sister my son's more
introverted and he needs his space and
his baby sister loves climbing on his
head while he's reading i can show up to
my son's frustration with his baby
sister i can see it i can summon it you
know i see you and by singing i bring
into being i can do all of those things
it doesn't mean i'm endorsing his idea
that he gets to give her way to the
first stranger he sees in a shopping
mall that's right we own our emotions
they don't own us
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free